that's the only thing you need a credit
score for and the truth is you don't and
I can tell you this because I am a
practitioner of this I was able to get
my mortgage which is now paid off
without any credit score wow is that
shocking
so why does everyone just seem to have a
credit card then it just it seems as we
are asking the same question every day
on the Ramsey show it's called marketing
think about how many I want you to watch
TV the next three or four nights you you
youngsters don't watch right Network TV
watch how many commercials there are for
a credit card and your parents are are
not dumb people they're smart but they
just fell for the normal American traps
of well you got to have your credit
score to build your credit and how do
you do that well you got to go into debt
and you got to pay it perfectly and get
more debt so that you can get a perfect
credit score but everything that they
say you can't do with that a credit
score I have done